depuis samedi soir à magny les hameaux
impossible de faire ses courses ou le
plein d'essence dans ce supermarché
et pour cause s'il enseigne n'a pas fait
faillite elle doit cependant céder les
locaux sur décision de justice
problème aucune information officielle
pour les clients très en colère très en
colère comprennent pas on a beaucoup de
nourrice et dans la région va même on a
beaucoup de personnes âgées
donc on a vu ce matin sont venus c'était
encore qu'il n'était pas encore au
courant donc ça ça donne pas mal dé
chambouler aussi quand même pendant une
semaine la vingtaine d'employés vide le
magasin avant pour certains d'endosser
les couleurs du repreneur intermarché
on m'a proposé de continuer avec le
groupe dans un autre magasin mais
malheureusement ça magasin qui est
relativement éloignées moi qui habite
juste sur la commune de m'a dit ça me
faisait trop loin des coûts a trop
important au niveau des transports donc
je reste avec intermarché
ça pose aucun problème du côté de la
mairie même si on regrette une fermeture
aussi brutale l'arrivée de la nouvelle
enseigne symbolise la relance de la
dynamique commerciale locale
le groupement va apprendre va prendre
possession du lieu à partir du 17
le temps de re approvisionner l'ensemble
de changer quelques éléments de
rafraîchir un petit peu mais pour
pouvoir rouvrir le plus vite possible et
à partir de septembre
on espère à partir de septembre des
séries de travaux de réhabilitation sur
les extérieurs voire sur les intérieurs
au fur et à mesure
la station essence devraient rouvrir le
mardi 18 juin le supermarché accueillera
lui ces nouveaux clients le mercredi 26
juin